MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So this is our last video in
the chapter on neutrino physics.
And we'll talk about mass scales
and the nature of the neutrino
particle very briefly.
When we think about how we can
measure the neutrino masses,
there's a number of
methods which come to mind.
The first one is to just
look out into the universe
and try to understand
how much matter in total
could come from as a
source of neutrinos.
And one has to make
assumptions about the model,
the cosmological models at hand.
But if I accept those potential
biases or model dependencies,
one finds that there's
a potential reach
of this kind of measurements
of 20 to 50 MeV, millielectron
volts.
And the current best
limits are in the order
of 0.1 to 1 electron volt.
A second source, and I'll
talk more about this later,
is the study of
neutrinoless beta decay--
double beta decays.
Here, the current best limits
are on the order of 0.2
to 0.4 electron volts.
And there's a chance to reach
20 to 50 millielectron volts.
This kind of measurement
will also answer the question
whether or not the neutrino is
a direct particle or a Majorana
particle as we discussed
in earlier lectures.
And then there is the
more classical approach
of measuring the
mass of an neutrino
from the end point
spectrum of beta decays.
And so here the
current best limit
is from the Kartrin experiment.
And I talk about it
in the next slide.
And it's in the order
of one electron volt.
And there's a potential reach
to go down to 40 millielectron
volt. So currently
the range of limits
is in the order of 1 electron
volt or a bit better,
and when we'll be
able to go down
to limits in the order of 20
to 50 millielectron volts.
So here is a cartoon of
how those measurements are
being conducted.
One starts with tritium.
And it uses beta decay.
And this lecture overall
is a good first entry
into the nuclear physics program
where we discuss beta decays
and other nuclear
decays in more detail.
What we find here is
that you find an electron
and the neutrino--
antineutrino in this case--
being emitted.
And so the name
of the game is now
to measure the electron energy
as precisely as possible,
and then find a sensitivity off
the neutrino mass in the end
point spectrum.
And those small differences here
in the end point spectrum then
that leads to understanding
of the mass of the neutrino
because the total
energy in the collision
needs to be preserved.
And so the entire story here
is about how precisely can we
measure the energy
of the electron
in order to infer the
neutrino mass in that.
And so the latest results
came out last year
from the Kartrin
experiment and shows
that the result is consistent
with a neutrino mass of 0,
and that we can set an upper
limit at 90% confidence level.
That electron neutrino is
of mass of 1.1 electron
volt. Just as a reminder,
we measure the mass
of the electron neutrino
in this decay, which
is the sum of the
individual components, mass
eigenstate, which make
up the electron neutrino.
To just have historical context
in this discussion here,
we find that this
latest result is
an improvement of the
order of factor of 2
compared to previous result
by other experiments, which
had a very similar job
to measure the electron
energy in beta decays,
in the end point
spectrum of beta decays.
There's a new
approach, which has
been proposed by Joe
Formaggio here from MIT,
which changes the way
the electron energy is
being measured.
So the idea is to have the
decay happen in magnetic fields,
and use the cyclotron
radiation of single electrons.
So the advantage
here is that one
doesn't have to move
the electrons somehow
into a spectrometer, but
can immediately measure
the energy of the electron.
And the measurement
of the energy
then turns into a
measurement of the frequency
and basically measures
the cyclotron frequency
of the electron circling
around in a magnetic field.
And so it turns out that
one moves the measurement
of the energy of the
electron into a measurement
of a frequency.
And thus frequency
can be measured
with very, very high precision.
So there's some hope that
this kind of measurement
lead to very, very
precise results
of the energy of the electron
and with that the mass
of the neutrino.
So the last slide
here is now how can we
figure out whether or
not the neutrino has
Dirac or Majorana nature.
And this can be done,
or the high sensitivity
comes from so-called
neutrinoless double
beta decays.
So one starts with
nuclear decays
where two electrons are
emitted, but no neutrino.
And so this requires
that in this process
there's a transition
which includes
the neutrino where the neutrino
has to be its own antiparticle.
And that just means that the
neutrino is of Majorana nature.
This is being done by measuring,
again, the energy spectrum.
You typically have all kinds
of background contributions,
but also backgrounds from double
beta decays with two neutrinos.
So you see this spectrum here.
And then you look at the
end point of this part
here and find that there is
this peak, a precise sharp peak
of the energies of
the two electrons.
The issue is that forecasting
where this peak is
requires proper knowledge of
the dynamics inside the nuclei
here.
And those measurements
are being conducted.
There's many of them conducted
in various nuclear transitions
or decays.
And they haven't yielded
a positive result yet.
Research is still
going on on this end.